round 2 of the 2017 u.s. Chess  Championship in st. Louis the capital of  chess in the United States critical  games often lead to critical mistakes as  datacom Sookie discovered when he  blundered badly against version of  Cobian leaving the five-time champion in  complete shock at this early setback in  the event as all of the favorites on the  men's side drew some long and  hard-fought games four-time champion  Anna's response key and current Jam Nagi  for kids he scored powerful victories to  jump into a tie at the top of the  leaderboard as in pre-tournament  favorite arena crush who dodged a bullet  against Olympia teammates Athena Poyser  - not her first win as she makes a run  at her eighth championship the thrills  and spills continue as a player is  rounded to form round reaction at the  most prestigious national championship  in the world stars